les véhicules de gendarmerie ont bloqué
le périmètre autour du domaine porcheron
jusqu'en milieu d'après midi à
l'intérieur de la bâtisse deux corps
sans vie ont été retrouvés peu avant 9h
ce matin
les victimes étaient deux frères à la
tête du domaine viticole âgé d'une
cinquantaine d'années il travaillait
dans une cuve de fermentation en travaux
pour mise aux normes
le drame se serait déroulé ce mardi en
fin d'après-midi les victimes ont-elles
manqué d'oxygène dans cette cuve qui
peut dégager du gaz carbonique ou se
sont-elles électrocuté pour l'instant
seule certitude c'est bien la piste
accidentelle qui est privilégié et une
disqueuse thermique a été saisie par les
forces de gendarmerie l'enquêté en cours
devra tenter de déterminer les causes de
ce drame
ici à fontenay près chablis petit
village l'émotion est extrêmement vive
les deux victimes étaient bien connus du
reste des habitants pour la plupart
vignerons également